[Music]
yeah
that's him that's him and he sent that
riff and boy it is Monday December 18 in
the year 2017 lot going on and that's
tie nice and who showing up for you
showing up for you you know what there's
an the email came in a while back I said
tiny this is the exact email I sent to
tiny I said tiny people want to hear a
Christmas ballot with some vocals of
your own
what about either rockin around the
Christmas tree or any good Christmas
song you like can you get us one thanks
the fans love tiny and then I get this
from tiny yo-yo how about this jingle
bill dig dot dot dot tiny and he played
this as riff this homemade tiny sand
whoo from the depths of the earth from
the for the from the inner canals of
Mother Earth you know coming straight
out that frickin warm over in the center
of this fine planet we live on take one
more hit off of that jingle bells made
especially for you by tiny saying who
[Music]
and I was just checking down the line
there to see if he gives us any any
vocals there and we don't get any vocals
we don't get to hear that tiny and
people you know sending in beautiful
pictures and ideas of what tiny is you
know somebody sent in like a groundhog
type of character you know people have
you know sent him pictures uh somebody
sent in them you know picture of an
Indian man in a baby carriage you know
people have sent in different ideas you
know somebody somebody sent in a picture
of a like a little bit of like a mollusk
with glasses on like a smart mollusk in
a harp if you can picture a mollusk
playing a harp and and so people are
sending in all types of ideas of what
tiny is and and I guess to me what tiny
kind of has become has become you know
he's just become a joy provider I mean
he's just that he's that Verizon of Joey
because we reach out to tiny we asked
him for Joey and he sends it and that's
hit that's all he does that's all he
does and that's I mean you know what the
Year coming in closing in and I'm
starting to think about next year Matt
something that I want to do a little bit
more of to be honest dude I don't want
to be out here just beating other people
with my nuts you know and just you know
bringing sharp confetti to every party I
go to and you know I don't want to be I
don't want to be caught up in the circle
of whatever the problem is anymore you
know whatever's going on out I don't
want to be more of a you know I
don't want to be I doesn't want to be
that I want to be that tiny sand who
that just shows up with the riffs and
drops that sweet cabbage into your ear
any eight years you know that just fills
up your ear bowls with that sexy
sultry sound soup that's and who
[Music]
man he's a dirty little grifter isn't he
he's a dirty little grifter and I'll let
the whole song play out at the end of
the episode today welcome to this past
weekend it is again it is December 18 s
2017 and we're closing in on the end of
the year man it's wintertime the power
out at the Atlanta Airport if you heard
about that they shut it down that
tricity they shut down that Tris head a
and a shout out to my girl tricity
Walters actually they had an urban girl
when I was growing growing up in middle
school and I'm tricity from my hometown
tricity Walters and she could jump man
this girl could jump she jump over you
she would jump over you dude if she
didn't like you
she just had Springs just sent her legs
she was just she was probably damn 60%
60% you know dove or fallen and and she
would jump right over you speaking of
doves are fallen dude my cousin got bit
by a gay guy out here in Los Angeles you
know so you know been keeping tabs on
him you know some fever here and there
but everything I think he's gonna be
fine
man that was during a Halloween and he
hadn't fully recovered but he got bit by
a man on Halloween dressed up like a
baby deer like a phone and it was a gay
gentleman and I'm not sure if the fella
you know had misplaced my cousin for
someone else or what had happened my
cousin was walking out here on Highland
Boulevard and gay gentleman dressed up
like a baby deer came out of the hedges
and bit him and the man was you know bit
him on the back and left some you know a
little bit of teeth marks and some
cinnamon lip gloss on his back where he
my cousin got you know got a snack don't
they basically they're snacking on these
straight boys off a Highland Boulevard
so if you have a friend out here in Los
Angeles who's walking on Highland who's
straight have him taken uber you know
cuz they got these gay gentlemen dressed
up out there like
ears that are snacking on these straight
boys but but yeah here we are and
welcome to this past weekend thank you
guys for being here with me happy
holidays merry Christmas to you guys
people are gearing up you know I
remember this time of year when I was a
kid at school it was always like you
were going into the biggest break you
know the biggest break you had as a
child as a child was that Christmas
break you know when you were gearing up
and you were gonna be all for Christmas
you know and that was such a big time
and you know seeing your friends and you
know talking to all the things you were
gonna get like I even remember in
kindergarten we would go and sit you
know we had to get at the beginning of
kindergarten we our parents would drop
us off and we go sit on this big rug and
you know we watching morning cartoons or
whatever and the the morning cartoons
would be coming on but the commercial
breaks all the toys would show and all
the kids you be like I got that I'm
getting that I got that I'm getting that
I remember that being like the big thing
was during that you know that break to
just tell everybody you were getting
everything and sometimes some of the
boys would even you know say I'm getting
that and it would be like a girls you
know tee said or something and you'd be
like okay you know that boy wants some
different stuff you know he don't want
the Hemans you know he wants other
things you know he wants the sparkly
ponies in that and so that was always
kind of a unique experience when you you
know when one boy would just
accidentally freudian Li slip like you
know I want I got that and it would be
um you know it would be like a
sheera or a Care Bear you know a Care
Bear you know neck brace and Hospital
kind of setup for children that wanted
to play Hospital you know those were
those were all just different gifts they
held on tiny micro machines that was the
big gift arm and when I was young people
one of these micromachines little bitty
cars and that was the gift to get Micro
Machines and the guy would be like
commercial like do you he would talk so
fast you look do you want them like you
you want to micromachines I'm from New
York you know and they need we talk
about the micro machines but yeah that
was fun when you were a kid man getting
ready to be out of school you know it
was just a you know that crazy time and
Santa was coming and anything could
happen you know and then I would and
then as you get older it kind of you
know the Christmas break I remember like
in junior high opiate somebody would
have like a nice party it'd be a good
time when you first usually got drunk I
feel like it was during the holidays
because it was extra liquor around
there's always extra liquor around her
in the holidays if you notice that
there's always a little bit extra wine
more people are stopping by you know the
little bottle of brandy left out and you
can you can easily copy a little bit of
sipper here there you can get that
hitter you know and I remember we got
drunk one time over the net lanta and
filled some wine bottles with water and
went out there and threw them off the
overpass that cars going by and I really
regret some of that behavior you know
and I think it and this time of year I
start thinking about just things I
regret a little bit from the year you
know because this is kind of like a time
where this time of year for me things
slow down you know things out here in
Los Angeles kind of slow down like
people are on fire and like that so
everybody's you know people aren't
bitching and complaining as much about
everything you know people are you know
trying to save their homes and stuff
because they're dealing with real
and and in my life things just slow down
you know I'm going home for the holidays
I'm leaving on Thursday I'm pretty
excited and I get that you know I just
get that you know I get that slow down
feeling you know and I start thinking
about people that I've ran into over the
year
I start thinking if there's people that
I need to talk to or apologize to you
know just things I need to purge because
things I don't want to take into I don't
want to take into next year you know not
I don't want to I just want to be that
sweet riff or that shows up you know I
want to be there I want to be that first
place canary I don't know sometimes I
find myself just being this dodo bird
you know I just keep carrying around the
same with me the same lies the
same ridiculousness and it's not it just
doesn't help me out
wonder while my life doesn't evolve
sometimes and it's because it's hard for
it to evolve when when I got these thick
brake pads made out of Mon that
are stopping the rotors all the time you
know and I find that sometimes sometimes
I just you know I don't maybe I'm being
vague but it's like you know I'm just
staying in a relationship that I
wouldn't be in or I'm you know could be
a friend even like a friendship or just
a you know I'm staying in a job or I
know I'm not happy you know I'm keeping
texts chains going with that I know
there's no I didn't really have any
interest in somebody I'm just or you
know just I'm just keeping
alive it's like I'm a juggler but all my
balls in the air are you know
and maybe two or three real balls and
that's what I'd like to do I'd like to
drop those balls and get into
something real coming up you know you
know just so I can open up more
possibility for some legit in my
life you know and I know I say you know
all the time you know people comment
about that so I'm gonna try to keep tabs
on this episode I'll see how I do but
it's uh yeah II just wanna you wanna you
wanna you know I just wanna I want to be
juggling real so when people come
up and they see they're like oh that man
juggles real balls you know he's not out
there with these balls you know
he's not out there with these baloney
balls you know were these spam spheres
that boys juggling beef you know that
boys juggling ticket teriyaki so I want
to be juggling real meats next year and
that's one of my goals is to just be
juggling the real you know and to
get some people you know I got Chris
just it's a good time man you got
Christmas give out some gifts feel some
joy don't feel bad about yourself if you
don't have the nicest you ain't
giving somebody a you know some time
your neighbor you know one a new hose or
they wanna a saw you know you can get
him a saw you can't get him a saw you
know you can get everything I'm a
one-year my mother didn't have a lot of
money and she got us to eat 2-liter
sodas
from the gas station you know from a
fillip 76 or Conoco or whatever and man
you think we didn't have any fun with
those boy all day dude running around
shaking them up and spraying each other
you know and I remember mine was uh
cherry 7up Diet of course my mother was
real adamant about calories you know and
that was some how you gonna be
poor not have anything but then your
mother trying to keep you on some kind
of a diet Jesus Christmas and so but
yeah I remember one year we all got two
litre sodas and people's running around
just shaking them up and spraying each
other up and douse in each other with
orange drank and you know that beautiful
cherry 7up and it was fun MAME so full
of soda I could you know my belly was
just distended with soda couldn't even
keep none of us could keep our pants on
so we had four children all under the
age of eight you know and everybody
pants all laying next to him even the
baby got their diaper laying next to him
because we gave her a bunch of soda you
know when you were young and nobody
cared if you filled the baby up with
soda pop now everybody's all risky about
everything everybody's gonna die or
everything is a disease you know but
when I was young sometime you filled the
baby you filled the baby with a little
bit of Mountain Dew diet you know you
put a little bit of Shasta you might put
you might you know you might uh top you
might top off a one-year-old with for a
little bit of Shasta
but now as so many rules Oh a soda will
kill a baby you're out of your mind did
I knew a three-year-old growing
up that could easily take down a quarter
grape that boy could take down a
quart of grape grape crush bubbly soda
not these little fake-ass kids now
people complaining and everybody all
their kid has you know I asthma
you know asthma if he can't breathe well
maybe it might be time to shut him down
you thought about that you know maybe
he's supposed to be out here in the
universe where people run on air if he
can't breathe
so long up
or long out baby that's what I'm saying
and go back to the Lord because
reincarnation man it's an easy fix
they'll patch you up and put you right
back here ready for real life so sorry
to go off on this tangents air but I'm
feeling frisky man I'm feeling wild I'm
feeling excited I get to see my family
this week you know my knees got a new
rabbit they got a show rabbit over there
I'm gonna go see my mother I'm trying to
get her so a couple of goats for
Christmas and she doesn't want them she
doesn't want the goats and so I am you
know I'm stuck with this dilemma like
what do i do what do I get my mother
these goats because I here's the thing
you know I know that I know that my
mother loves goats and she won't ask me
for them in fact when I said um would
you like some goats and I'm talking to
goats I'm not talking a bunch because
here's the backstory my mum my mum my
mother always wanted have a goat farm
because she likes you know natural
animals you know she likes natural you
know milk and all that so she's thinking
you know she'd like to farm a few goats
have her own goats but she's always you
know I'll do it later when I have more
land or when I have this or that but the
thing is those times might never come
and so I start worrying that you know
that my mother's gonna be afraid to ask
for things that she wants because she
thinks it's gonna put a burden on me but
that her dreams or whatever you know
even if her dream is something a little
like having a few goats you know that
her dreams aren't gonna come true if she
don't have them goats so that's where my
mind is that it's like man I want to get
my mother these goats but you know what
she says she doesn't want him but I want
her to be happy and I really believe
that that this would help make her happy
because it would kind of help her
achieve one of her dreams of being a
goat owner and having you know you know
being able to have natural milk out of
animals at the house but that she's
afraid to ask so it's tough it's tough
to navigate that it's tough to you know
do I get my mother something just
because I think that she
wants it because I think it would be
helpful to her or do I listen to her
when I asked her do you want any of you
know would you like a goat and it was
just gonna be one go but the thing is
about goats is that you can't leave them
alone you know goats are like I mean
they're like you know goats are like
goats just don't they don't want to be
alone goats are not singular animals
you'll never see a goat usually out by
itself you know if you see a goat
walking down the road you usually see
one or two goats three goats more but
you're not gonna just see one goat out
milling around hitchhiking
that's because goats like to
have a friend they get very very lonely
and I just thought it'd be nice my
mother could look out the back porch and
see a couple goats out there and I know
it'd bring joy to her but you know she's
just I just worry she's putting off the
things that'll make her happy because
she thinks her life isn't ready right
now for him but then it is our life ever
gonna be ready you know is her life
gonna change that much in the next 10
years where she's suddenly gonna live on
a big ranch and have room for animals I
don't know you know but it's just tough
I don't know it's like I want to be
helpful but goats really can help can
kind of take care of themselves I think
I'm gonna do a little more research on
it but yeah I remember my mother got us
some two-liter sodas one time when were
yelling we had one of the best
Christmases that we ever had shaken him
up and spraying him out and just getting
that whole body's covered in soda you
know I remember hugging my little sister
at the end of the day and could barely
even separate our we were so sugared
down so covered in sugar our skin can
barely separate you know and that's I
know that's a little bit erotic but it's
not supposed to be it's just supposed to
be about our sugar drinks but yeah it's
a good time of year man it's a good time
of year just show up you don't have a
gift show up and say look I don't have a
gift but I love you drop hit hit
somebody with that ale bomb you know
instead of drawing a dick on somebody's
head when they're passed out won't you
draw ah right love you on their on their
forehead you know send them back out in
the world sharing the message so also I
heard that a couple of
has made it over to grey block pizza and
pick them up because that's where you
get it at man great block pizza they got
it all and that's over there
GRE why BL o ck pizza calm
they got cows Onis salads and they got
the salad pizza oh you didn't think that
a pizza could be green and fancy and you
might even find a rabbit hopping through
it because it's that vegetable ish well
you're dead wrong they get the salad
pizza over there great block but what's
going on in my life man this weekend
what I'd done just it you know I did
some comedy sets I'm recovering from
this surgery so I got this surgery last
week and I know you can probably hear
that I sound a little bit better this
week and so I got this surgery last week
where they go inside of your not your
brain but in your face and they wide and
they were breathing canals so if you
hear me right now man I'm I got I'm
taking a real hit off the world when I
inhale man I mean it whereas before I
was like you know a little bit cranky
but now I'm a hundred percent but I'm
taking the hit I'm getting that hit and
so that's what I'm feeling I'm feeling
this more lively more vibed up and but
it's been it's been a tough week you man
a lot of fever I think this was a tough
week to be a little bit sick or feeling
the odd because you know the weather is
changing and people are getting nervous
and all that kind of stuff you know and
I saw my holster my whole brain they go
in there and they chip out so all week
man I'm clearing my throat and I'm
bringing up pieces of man I'm
bringing up memories from when I was
nine you know I mean they're getting in
there deep and they're getting that
nasty nasty and they're blowing daddy
out but it was a it was an interesting
weekend I saw the video I know people
have seen the video now of the f-18
fighter pilots I had an alien an alleged
alien that these guys caught on video
not caught in real life and it's
interesting you know you got this video
of this alien ship vessel going against
the wind and the winds are supposed to
be like 100
miles an hour but now what you don't
know is I mean just watching the video
it's like were these were where the
pilots voice is dubbed in later is that
real
just how much of it is real you know cuz
these days anything can be made you know
anything it's like everything out and
most of the stuff you see out there you
know a lot of it's you know I
remember when those videos came out it's
like Oh watch what happens with this
when this homeless guy doesn't accept
the dollar you know and instead he does
breakdancing or something that was all
faked it all that all depend
on all those videos were fake you know
this guy Fauss was making fakie
and so you look back into some of this
stuff and you're like now when you go
back and watch TLAs a lot of those
videos you know watch what happens when
this black baby doesn't know that he's
black you know cuz he's blind and you
know he you know he gets treated
perfectly at the mall and you're like
what the is this about you know
watch this caterpillar here zydeco music
for the first time you know watch this
all deaf kitten taste London broil beef
for the first time ever because of a
taste blood transplant from Russia but
it's all that kind of we like what
the going on but all the videos
are made to look exists there's no it's
just it's like these little bitty
30-second videos to just prove
somebody's point but show no other
perspective and a lot of them is
man it's like that's what's out
there now so I'm just worried that this
aliens that that's what's going on
you know cuz I'm trying to get this
out of my brain bowels cuz I
got thing chorea
I got thing Korea man that's what I
noticed that I have it's just my
thoughts are just infected with a bunch
of straight-up fart feces man and it's
all just hot air that's come out of this
universe I mean so much that I
listen to and absorb every day is
valueless and so I got to start taking
control I gotta stand here at the
frontlines of my life and not let so
much in you know and it's tough
man it's tough because also they enter
it's entertaining that's the thing it's
like watch what happens with this when
this guy with zero legs and arms you
know watch what happens when somebody
sets a piece of steak on his back and
he's laying on his stomach in the you
know on the street on the sidewalk watch
what happens when somebody sets a fresh
steak on his back and then you watch and
instead of the guy like you know just
leaning him back and eating the steak
off his own back he pulls it off his
back and gives it to like climbs a tree
with no arms and legs into a bird's nest
and give the steak to the birds and
you're like oh okay yeah sure that's
what happened and then it's like don't
be alone you know white people suck you
know then that's what the video you're
like what the is this about you
know it's just a lot of this just you
know all the videos were just made to
look like it just it's like hey guess
what this exactly you know it's just man
there's a lot of out
there because the truth is if a man up
there with no arms and legs the only
person I've seen out there with no arms
and legs is doing all these shows extra
I saw him performing to church about
eight months ago and he does these shows
where he travels around the country and
performs and does like inspirational
speaking so that's the reality
you know that's the reality of it is
that a lot of these people out there
doing shows they're not out there
trying to eat steak off their
own backs so you just got a look at the
real you gotta look for the reality
that's what I'm trying to do these days
minutes look a little bit more for the
reality so pretty a pretty good weekend
you know Bitcoin everybody's up into the
Bitcoin and you might know that I got
you know some of you saw my Twitter I'm
gonna be in a film or tape a next spring
late spring it's called Bitcoin the
movie so I'm pretty stoked to kind of
see you know what that'll be like
assuming that it goes through you know
all the paperwork's done but we got to
get there and
it happened but bitcoin is out there
right now and I just heard you guys to
go cautiously you know I remember when
they came into my town when I was young
and they had glitter mining and people
are investing in glitter mining thousand
here 2000 there and me and my buddy
Chucky man each went in a thousand in
the glitter mining they had the
brochures they had sample glitter
you know they had rock glit rock and we
were we were sent a syncline and hooker
and then turn out glitters
manufacturer there are no mines all cat
grade-a deep not even realistic George
Orwellian fictional catch it
and that's and then we lost our money so
you just got to be careful out there you
don't know what's actually gonna be
realistic you know I think this camera's
not really focusing that much so I want
to tell you guys about some dates I have
coming up January 11th through the 14th
I'll be at the Brea improv so that's one
thing
January 18th through the 20th I'll be a
Jacksonville at the comedy club and I'll
be at the La Jolla Comedy Store and that
is January 6th that is February 16th
through the 18th so those are some dates
coming up in my universe and I'm feeling
a lot of feelings man I'm feeling a lot
of one thing I want to do like I was
saying is get some things off my chest
before this year turns and and one of
those I'm gonna do right now with a call
you know I'll call this call came in
many months ago and and I should have
got to it and I don't know if I didn't
because I was ashamed or if I was yeah I
don't know what's telling my thoughts
and feelings were but I want to get to
it now and here we go all right and I
know the audio is rocky on this but it's
just the best that they have is how the
call came in and this is a young as a
gentleman saying that they came out to
the show in Addison
and that they came out to the show and
that we all hung out after me and him
and he had a cute date let's hear more
okay I'm pretty sure you remember and I
do I do remember and just a great night
and a couple nights later that girl and
while he's talking about the videos I'm
gonna say don't forget to subscribe on
YouTube and this is not the most
opportune time for me to mention that
but if you subscribe on YouTube I will
appreciate that and that's just a dark
joke because you know this guy's here
sharing his feelings so the girls over
at his house and they're watching you
know he's just being supportive he's
showing her funny stuff all word I'm
putting a and that's just figuratively I
think I don't even know what
figuratively means it means the one
where it doesn't really happen let's
hear more she starts crying
the starts crying I'm like this
crying right now and come to find
out and so a couple things right there
you know I mean for one and I'll just
bring it up you know he says this
you know and I mean that part kind of
turned me off in the call but I think
he's probably at the time of this call
was angry at this young lady you know
and I could understand and I couldn't
understand being angry at her and I can
understand him being angry at me and
he's saying that you know he's over this
place he's playing videos you know you
know they're talking about what a good
time he's talking he's talking about
what a good time they had at the show
that they enjoyed my show we had fun
hanging out after which we did and then
a few nights later that she snuck over
to meet up with me for a little bit of
that Hank paint
and then she's crying and she tells him
that I kind of caught me off guard
and I like my favorite comedian and I do
recollect that the woman had a nice ass
he's saying if I was in your shoes and I
saw that ass that I would go in you know
I get you know aim for that ass get up
in that ass you know like like Ben
Affleck and that big black guy in
Armageddon when they try to get up on
that rock in the air and save the
universe with Steve Buscemi and you know
I got you know I got a couple of
different thoughts you know you don't
really blame me
I appreciate this call man you know
let's let's hear you out let's hear you
out I hope you'll include this on your
podcast so people can know a little bit
more about your life and what life is
like on the road and yeah I kind of want
to thank you I was thinking about Oh in
that part I'm gonna cut it there you
notice cuz I mean I heard it before and
he you know he liked her and he was
thing about dinner seriously and then
because of you know what happened with
me and Hurd then then it made him
realize that it wasn't the best case
scenario and I want to apologize man you
know and I texted him personally I left
him a voicemail personally to apologize
and and I you know I mean I feel I feel
bad you know definitely my behavior you
know the girl reached out to me and we
ended up hooking up and getting involved
in some American sex you know nothing
wild nothing foreign and not even good
sex you know I'm not good at
so it was bad it was that faint and goat
kind of syndrome that I hear that I get
sometimes you know where you know you
start going and next thing you know you
just holding your breath and then you
faint like those animals on the internet
like those shy goats and that's kind of
what happened to me you know and that's
you know and I've never really been good
at sex I was real good at sex I think
wouldn't tell about 19 you know when uh
when you when sex is more popular when
you were sober you know in sober sex is
for children I think you know adults
that are sober that is
awkward that's just really awkward I
think but sober sex I've always taught
was for children but yeah man she uh you
know she reached out and I complied I
remember the moment that I got this
message from her and I'm thinking man
should I be doing this you know here was
a you know fellow that came out to the
show we had a good time I'm her and we
all went out to the bar and hung out you
know and this is probably about a year
ago and and it was yeah and I knew that
the answer was no but then that's when
something boiled up inside of me you
know it was almost like a caterpillar
climbed out of my nuts with a message
from my dick and crawled all the way up
into my brain and gave that message it
was almost like Paul Revere a little bit
you know he's coming and climbed into my
brain and once that Paul Revere that
that cat appalled that catapult got into
my brain I couldn't relax I couldn't I
couldn't fight the message at that point
you know I couldn't stop myself and
that's just you know it was a series of
reactions then you know I'm texting with
the gallon I kept I remember almost not
it really hanging it spinning you know
she was a beautiful girl and I mean I'm
just sorry man I don't know if I'm you
know just going in circles here I'm just
trying to give a little bit more
background of the story but I'm sorry
you know I shouldn't have done that
you know but then you know sometime I
just can't help but be you know I was
that man
you know I was that wild man out there I
wouldn't have it enough you know morale
for myself to hold on the moon nut you
know I was trying to get out there and
be wild with that you know with my body
you know and get out there and be in
people's orifices and everything you
know and be like a real you know just
loitering around people's orifices and
women this woman's orifices and I just
want to say that I'm sorry man I
appreciate you appreciate you calling
and talking about it and and I apologize
and I want to let people know that if
you you know come out to the show with
your lady that that's not the type of
thing it is you know I'm not out there
trying to seek and destroy anybody's
relationships or anybody's first dates
and I remember this was a first date
scenario and now I'm just kind of
backpedaling I guess maybe trying to
defend myself here but you know but I
should have manned up and been like
that's you know but I went out
there and tried to catch that you know
try to catch that cooter frisbee in my
mouth you know like a wild Australian
Shepherd and that's what I did you know
and I and I just you know at least
they're very least brother know that it
was bad sex that I'm the bad that I'm
the you know I'm that bad sex bandit you
know I'm that bone Ranger you know I'm
that bad sex bandit I'm in and I'm I'm
I'm in and then I mean I'm in and out of
there like it's a bank you know get in
try to get the money shit's awkward
there's an alarm there's an old man with
a gun there's a black security guard
he's arresting and next thing you know
I'm out of there and it was not a good
show no money and now a a rap sheet and
this is my rap sheet man and this is you
know this is the truth and I just wanted
to put some skin in the game too on this
on this podcast because guys call all
the time and share things that are you
know real in their life and kind of
explore who they are and women do too
and sometimes I don't know if I'd do
that enough but yeah man I just want to
apologize you know I don't think I
should have done that behavior it's not
behavior that I'm proud of and here's
why I know I should apologize because at
this point hearing back on it when I
heard this call
I knew it wasn't something I was proud
of you know you know I knew it wasn't
something I was proud I knew that I you
know that I was that sneak you know that
I was that Hamburglar and I'm out there
stealing this the meat rounds you know
I'm out there stealing them
titty patties you know I'm not there
stealing them titty patties in them
vagina nuggets you know while this man's
out there you know you know sharing a
shake with his lady two straws into a
chocolate cup and I'm out there sneaking
around back and sneaking around with
them
titty patties in them you know vagina
nuggets so I'm sorry dude and uh and if
you come out again do next year or
whenever I come back there I think I've
even been back there once sense but if
you come back again man I got tickets
for you you know and uh and I I won't
I won't even talk to your date at all or
look at her and and and that's that man
you know that's what happens so um
that's it bro that's it dude and you
know I just want to appreciate you
calling I appreciate you having the
balls to call me on it and uh you know
it's not the person that I want to be to
do this out there that's you know giving
in just to try and catch a little bit of
that you know to catch a little bit of
that slick wallet from any local lady
and that's not the man I am now but I
can't say that when that opportunity
when that happened that I wasn't that
man so but onward bro and thank you
alright let's hear a call here we got
this one from animal man people no
animal man is calling over the air and
it's that time of year when animals you
know it's wintertime for animals and a
lot of animals you know you won't see
them they're hibernate you know even
though they got I saw some animals say
this lady had two little bitty dogs and
let me tell you this ladies some of you
ladies with these little bitty dogs what
the you doing because some of these
aren't dogs okay some of these are
little it's just urine
security with four legs that's all it is
some of these are little figment of your
imagination that you're that you are a
buying from who knows where that mother
nature is creating the mother
nature never created some of these
little fake-ass animals I remember I was
alive in 1992 half these dogs didn't
exist they look like a little
cold reindeer what are some of these
animals here's my thing if a frisbee
will kill it is it a dog that's where I
draw that line because I see some of
these ladies just walking these things
that are not they're not even they all
have emphysema and they all have you
know brain surgery and they're wearing
colostomy bags and because they're
they're not real they weigh three pounds
that's not a animal that's a
science experiment
and it's just some of it you you see
that you see the dog and you're like
just something wrong with this thing
it can't breathe its eyes coming to
separate carrying case on that they wear
on the back and you got to pull out and
put them in its head I mean it's some of
these dogs it's not even real they can't
eat anything they have two sips of water
it's just it's just scary some of its
not real and so as much as we're you
know people are trying to rescue animals
in this kind of having these fake
animals is just that's scary very scary
man so if I kind of you know I was
talking about do you ever wonder why we
continue to be served up the same cookie
cutter content or how many times
Hollywood can remake you know Beauty and
the Beast Beauty and the Beast go to
Barbados Beauty and the Beast in
Afghanistan you know bill gets a burka
how long is it gonna go on how many
sequels can be milked out of our
favorite franchises when do we just say
enough is enough with these bad movies
Baywatch
Baywatch but on skates what the is
that well times have changed guys and
those times and those changes are at
live tree
come because live tree is changing the
entertainment industry by creating a new
platform called adept that's right
adept is set to disrupt a 500 billion
dollar entertainment industry's entire
value chain and gamify the process of
watching content the public that means
us will now be able to fund what they
want to watch own what they helped
produce and decide who's in it and what
goes on through the process of content
creation funding and distribution it's
like just say Hollywood suddenly was a
fantasy football league and you could
put who you want in what projects you
could move them forward and you could
have a part of the back end you could be
a producer you can change the game and
you can do it at live tree dot-com check
it out it's it's magic they're making
magic happen and this is the beginning
of it but let's hear a little bit more
oh we had animal man : let's hear a
little bit more from animal man here we
go hey this is your animal man coming
again being Christmas time thinking
about Santa's reindeer I thought I'd
share a story but when I had to kick a
caribou in the face
Gang Gang Gang Gang because everybody
wants to find animals of sweet and
animals are nice oh look at the video on
Instagram of the Panda
oh he's balancing on a ball of snow look
at him well guess what there's also the
mean streets of Detroit where
these animals are out there let's hear
more I was up on the North Slope of
Alaska and the spring time early May do
you see the snow still on the ground
driving along looking for migratory
birds bang bang boy lot of dudes get
stoned and uh let's go you know let's
get some of these takis you know let's
eat some hot chips let's cook a pizza in
the dryer guy but that but the big dog
animal man he's out there on the North
Slope of Alaska looking for migratory
birds now that's the kind of weed that I
want to hit that that puts you out
there on the on the North Pole you know
out there watching
and you know little people build trains
and let's hear more and I saw
something a couple hundred yards off the
side of the road kind of a lump in the
cenotes so he pulled over and I could
see with the caribou it looked like it
was just lying on the ground sleeping so
I honked my horn a couple times and it
didn't react at all
yeah that's sleeping caribou trick man I
used to play that one time on this girl
I was dating you know that'll sleep and
caribou and then next thing you know
everybody's you know and
everybody is because they want to
be doing sex not because somebody's
sneaking up on somebody let's hear more
I watched it for a few minutes and I
couldn't even see him breathing
so I'm one of the things dead so I get
out of the car started trudging over to
it it hadn't moved at all it hadn't
breathed and I stopped him looking a few
times I got closer and closer and just
assumed it was dead it had been a big
storm for a few days and I thought I had
froze that frozen caribou trick oh yeah
this is definitely this is more of a
gangbang maneuver more so I kind of
stopped paying attention as I got closer
to it because if it was alive usually it
wouldn't have got up and run away I get
up to the thing and suddenly it stands
up and looks at me and let go this
little grunt and so I grunted back and
this thing is getting very like Al
Pacino in heat tell if you ever seen
that movie heat or not where it's him
and Robert De Niro are upset at each
other about guns let's hear more and the
next thing I know the thing charges
right at me I was only about 10 15 feet
away so it didn't have any time to
really react so I just kicked it in the
face can you a matte like can you
imagine that kicking a caribou in the
face you know I've heard of people talk
about the rusty trombone and the
cinnamon donkey or whatever it's called
but to kick in the caribou in the face
that's a real move that's a real move
animal man out there dude
who can't even fathom you would do that
what else but it wasn't even cool karate
kind of kick I just kind of did a little
hacky sack going off the side because it
happened so quick it's so then we looked
at each other and laid down
and just there to me and so I was like I
won't get my hell out of here went on
with the rest of my day and came back in
the afternoon and I was still there and
I watch it for awhile I was struggling
to get up couldn't really get up at all
actually so I stopped the truck and
watched it got a walk closer to it and
actually so I'd die so yeah I felt bad
that the thing was gonna die anyways and
had made it through this storm just
barely it was completely starved and it
was a beautiful day and I could have
just died in peace but the last thing
that happened to it was some idiot comes
out of nowhere and kicks it in the face
man oh you know and I appreciate you
sharing that story here with us because
there is something a little tragic about
that you know he thinks he's you know
animal man he's out there and thank you
for calling animal man from the North
slopes of the great white north out
there who knows what's happening he
could have been anywhere he's out there
battle in the snow where are you
at at home right now eating a you know
watching JibJab videos and eatin sliced
meat and animal man's out there living
real life kind of
you know living real you know Swiss
Family Robinson type of and we're
doing but we're I were over here
pissed off because we you know our hot
coco ain't right you know we're the
sandwiches is too small or cuz our aunt
is our aunt is getting fat or our
girlfriend's getting thick but animal
man I feel you man you know I can really
relate to that story dude of when you
have that moment where you you don't
recognize the scenario of what's going
on and you do something so just trite so
meaningless so stupid so out of line
with what the music of that mother
nature is playing at that moment and you
know here's an animal that's dying you
know in the last living creature that it
encounters is a man you and and it's
both you know it's a swan song and it's
head there's these romantic songs going
on and
you know maybe there's like Miss America
V's or something but then you you
don't you don't you're you're viewing it
wrong you got this whole Rodney King
kind of thing going on and next thing
you know you kick this animal in the
face you know and then it you come back
later in the day and it's you see it die
and you realize wow you know I
apparently am out of tune with nature
and that's why and first I'll tell you
my story that relates to that the story
is this when I was let me see 12 years
old and in my town they had a boy named
Ricardo and he played basketball with us
and he was tall he was the tallest boy
I'd ever seen he was taller than any man
I've ever seen and he was only a boy and
he was probably six five and he probably
weighed 230 pounds and he had the
biggest smile I mean his smile you know
if he if he had been wearing lipstick he
would have got it he'd have got lipstick
on the tips of his ears when he smiled
his smile was so big it just you know it
almost just hugged his entire face and
he was a beautiful handsome kid black
gentleman african-american and he were
playing basketball and Reggie Lewis had
just died for the Boston Celtics and
Reggie Lewis was a famous basketball
player who collapsed on the court I
believe in practice and passed away of
heart condition literally a few days
later were playing basketball in our
town it's like a you know a city game
and Ricardo's running down the court and
he falls he just falls on the court and
I remember yelling from the bleachers I
remember yelling Reggie Lewis who is the
player for the Celtics who had just
passed away in the NBA and I don't know
why I did it you know I thought he was
just had fallen down I thought that this
young man had just fallen down he was
gonna be okay
and then next thing you know the
ambulance has come and he never got up
and I remember being at his funeral a
few days a few days later and uh just
scared and heartbroken just because you
know that experience was someone you
know leaving the earth but also you know
some shame because here I was
doing something that was so out of line
with what Mother Nature's plan was at
that moment you know with what God's
plan was at that moment Here I am just
being a tool bag
you know just yelling Reggie Lewis and I
worry someone with that the last thing
that he heard what happened but then I
know that some of those ideas are just
selfish ideas of me thinking that like
that's crazy you know you know the last
thing you heard was some beautiful you
know something you know the salt clean
freshly soap washed hands of the Lord
coming down and picking him up and
taking him to a safer place but that was
a you know your story just made me think
about that and thought about that in
many years but I appreciate you calling
in animal man and you know and we you
know we share these things like this to
get them off of our chests to purge them
because I don't we don't want to go into
next year you know next year we're not
kicking Caribous in the face we're gonna
be congruent with what's going on we're
gonna be in the flow when I carry any
no extra baggage let it go if
you have to tell somebody something tell
them if you got to get it off your chest
if you're in love if you're out of love
you know if your son is being a prick
you know if your cousin's breath stinks
let's get on the same page let's share
the news guys let's purge if you need to
make a call and leave a voicemail to
somebody and let them know that they
you up or that they bullshitted
you or that you invested something you
were you know you were vulnerable you
know get it done I'll probably have a
few that I need to make and I and I'm
glad I'm thinking about it right now I'm
glad you guys are here with me to think
about it I'm glad you guys are here with
me to think about it you know we are we
got a few more calls that came in and we
had some people that responded we had a
young lady that called last week saying
how does she get out of the friendzone
and and we'll get into that in just a
second but I want to I want to play a
call that came in from a caller right
here thank you for calling hotline and
the hotline is nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three in the New
Year I'd like to get back to you know if
people are having issues out there
you know if you're struggling of course
with anything calling about it if I can
relate I'll share my experience also if
you're struggling with addiction or some
issues like that feel free to call just
don't want you feeling alone because
you're not let's take this call here we
go again the hotline nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three you'll
have up to three minutes to leave a
message
and and I appreciate all the voicemails
that have come in thank you very much
thinking of how all these people calling
in on these checking in on you make sure
doing well feel like your friends are
calling you is feel like any connection
to be do or they just random strangers
just kind of callin checking in on you
or like friends that are calling to see
how you doing hey it's a good question
comment thank you for calling thank you
for hitting the hotline does it feel
like my friends are calling when I get
these voicemails ah well it's hard for
me to say that it feels like they're
calling when you know they're bringing
dates to the shows and you know I'm
finagling them so that doesn't feel good
you know so I mean unless up I mean
that's I guess that's the kind of friend
that I was though at that at that point
you could be like well maybe you're
being hard on yourself and yeah it's
true maybe I am being a little bit
aggressive with myself a little
assertive but you know but if I don't
want to have the same behaviors I got to
be assertive you know I got to drop that
line in the sand you know I gotta get
that marks a lot out and start to uh and
start to draw a box around myself and
look at where my lines are and look at
what my levels are because otherwise
I'll just be you know otherwise it's
just you're just walking around forever
but but does it feel like here sometimes
it does you know especially with some of
these guys called about addiction some
of these guys call about you know things
that they're dealing with in their life
and you can tell a lot of times in
somebody's voice if there's something
they're really struggling with if
they're just joking around and sometimes
it's okay if it's any of it if people
are joking around and it's
call it fits with the with the upcoming
episode good let's do it you know and if
people are talking about something
serious and I can put it out there where
other people can call and help them then
that makes me feel like a little bit of
part of some solution I guess like a
little bit of like a middleman you know
and that's something I'd like to do more
of in the coming years match people up
who are having problems and people who
need suggestions and who have really
good suggestions because they have
experience and I think that's one thing
we're starting to do by you know
fielding issues and putting them out
there for you guys to call in and give
thoughts and suggestions to listeners so
yeah I guess it does feel like friends I
mean I'll let you know I get into the
hotline it I search on that Google inbox
and next thing you know there's you know
50 voicemails in there and it's like
damn what's going on some people call in
they just rambling some people call
every single week and I try to always
get one of their calls on but it doesn't
fit a little bit you know but I'm never
like I wish this person wouldn't
call anymore
I'm always grateful you know I tried to
test some people I'll just text them
back and just check in on them and see
what's going on you know I don't even
put the call up here on the show I just
text them and we will have a little bit
of a text communication and just see
what's going on if it's something that's
happening so it makes me feel I do think
it makes me feel good you know it makes
me feeling this may be selfish but it
makes me feel sometimes like you know
like I'm able to be you know part of
somebody else's universe a little bit
you know and I learn a ton of I
mean there's a lot of times there's a
lot of people will call them what the
just suggestions or advice from me or
links or information to things that I've
talked about in like dude this is where
you can get help for that or this is
where you can learn about that and I
appreciate those things so it's I guess
if it certainly feels like a community
it feels like we're starting a community
so that feels good you know and I love
the suggestions about what we should do
for next year on the podcast and things
like that and I love the fact we have
some ladies calling in you know there's
been a crazy year especially as a man
you know this has been a year I've asked
myself
you know how racist am I am i racist
where does racism lie within me you know
when um that take a nice stuff and a lot
of the you know political division in
America this year I feel like for me it
had me asking a lot of questions to
myself even in even innately even when I
didn't want to be asked him I was just
like you know I would cease I would see
you know I would I would start to
monitor how I behaved around people of
other genders and other ethnicities it
really did it just made me start to
think start to look at myself you know
like oh when I see a black friend I when
I see a white friend do I behave any
differently even if it's just a little
bitty thing is there any reason for it
you know when I see when I'm talking to
a girl or talking to a guy do I is my
demeanor different is there any do I
carry any air of superiority and one or
inferiority in us in one conversation as
opposed to another you know these are
things that I started to really look at
myself from this year or look into this
year and a lot of that is because of I
guess just kind of groupthink of what's
going on in the world and then us
talking about some of these things at
the same time on the pod you know on
this past weekend because the truth
there's a lot of my weekends there's
just shitty you know this weekend I was
my nose was felt wide open so the whole
weekend all the air every breath I took
it felt cold I coughed up something from
long the other day i from the back of my
head it came dislodged from the inside
of my skull it came out of my mouth and
it felt like a damn zygote the single is
huge I'm talking this thing was probably
two and a half inches about two and a
half inches and probably weighed about a
sixteenth of a pound and it just came
out of me you know from the little
procedure I had done but now you hear
that thing running boy like a 280zx boy
don't even bring an Eightball around
this thing son don't even bring an
Eightball but last week we had a call
that came in a young
lady asking about you know she's always
in the friend zone and we had some some
callers that gave him suggestions for
her here
so I'm gonna drop those in right now
here's a couple of suggestions that came
in for you from some of our callers
yo Rico from New Hampshire
Rico out of that HAMP boy Rico out of
that HAMP Oh more Rico calling about the
friendzone
this goes for male females in there if
you're in the friend zone talk to the
person immediately tell them the truth
tell them that you have feelings for
them they will you say yes I have
feelings for you and this in these case
I'm assuming that the male is gonna say
yeah let's get it on I think I'm in the
friend zone too which is usually the
case it's just people not not talking to
each other so we say in that
miscommunication that's a bit it's a key
right up front so young lady if there's
if there's a specific instance because
you just kind of said that generally
guys feel like you know it seem like
you're in the friend zone automatically
if there's a specific instance that
you're trying to you know capture a
man's heart are you trying to be
sentimental with him or sit in a park
somewhere and split a sandwich you know
and look at the fountains or whatever
then you need to let that man know that
you have more desires than just sitting
around watching roller derby or kind of
like that you know that you have
the desires to be sensual you know do
you have that sandwich together tell
them how you feel if they say no you
just keep doing you keep being yourself
don't don't try and be what you think a
guy's gonna just be yourself and people
that are like you are gonna gravitate
toward you yeah in the end there is this
general advice I think you know people
like you're gonna gravitate towards you
but you've you in that friend zone speak
up you know say hey you know just party
a one over here and I'm trying to make
it part of it too and I think then
people will recognize let's hear another
call here that came in hey this is Paul
calling in from Northeast Ohio dan
that's quiet Paul boy Paul sounds like
that silent killer boy like emphysema
Paul sound like he's hiding yeah
you know but he's not trying to hurt
anybody he just up there living you know
and not telling you about it let's hear
more Paul thank you for calling brother
I'm calling in about the jumping out of
the friend zone and one man Paul got
that deep voice huh
he sound like he'll you in a
basement or something he'll you at
the center of the earth boy Paul got
them long consonants coming out of his
face Luther Vandross boy let's hear a
little more over Paul his own and one
thing that I noticed when I'm hanging
out with the girl who if we're just
friends if she shows any kind of like
physical contact towards me I it piques
my interest and I just allows me to know
that she is maybe kind of interested in
me as more than a friend
thanks man over the podcast just trying
to help out and there you go and so
right there I think this goes back to -
does this feel like your friends are
calling you I mean that's somebody just
calling just to help out that's somebody
who was sitting around listening heard
something felt compelled and then called
just to help out so yeah I think in that
sense it really does and I'll see guys
on the road I'll say this I'll go out
and do shows and perform and I'll see
guys come out on the road who loved the
podcast and I'm like wow that's amazing
who feel like we're onto something we're
putting something together you know cuz
I'm not here struggling to man and I'm
sure next year is gonna be a struggle
you know but I know that we got some
groupthink going on here and I know that
um I feel like I could do a better job
of bringing some of my real problems
here to the pod you know I feel like I
really could you know I feel like
sometimes this year I got afraid to come
sometimes talk about things because I
was afraid to you know just afraid of
what I guess what people might think if
I shared some of my thoughts you know or
shared even just some of my questions
and I think that that's sometimes just a
part of our problem with our society out
here you know especially in Los Angeles
man you know I've never felt I don't
think less welcome in a place then I
feel here a lot of time
you know a lot of times they beat you
down or you know if you have you know
just feel unwelcome you know so you know
I have a southern accent and I you know
have some faith in a higher power and I
you know I'm not you know I'm not
liberal but I'm not conservative really
you know I don't I don't use one of
those really dude to find me you know
and I try to be understanding you know I
try to be understanding I just you know
I I feel like the underdog a lot of
times and I don't think that ever really
kind of has left me a little bit I don't
like it when people gang up on other
people and pick on somebody I don't like
that you know I feel bad if I if
somebody's you know is mean or hot or
heartless you know sometimes I feel I
feel bad for them because I know that it
must be hectic to go through life and be
grinching all the time you know it's not
easy people that sometimes are mean are
in pain really sometimes we don't want
to think that you know and I don't like
it if people should be able to know
better and do better and they don't
understand but you know it's tough it's
tough sometimes but then I realize that
I do the same exact things you know I'm
just learning as I go that's
what I'm trying to do and I think we're
all just trying to do that together but
I think we got to stick together out
there's a rocky world out there for men
and for women too should his gang gang
out there for 20 Gucci gang but that
physical contact he's saying he's saying
that's one way to get out of the
friendzone is did you do that touch you
know play a little why you know let's uh
thumb wrestle touch somebody's elbow
touch somebody's cheek you know
sometimes physical touch even if you
don't know what to do I remember a buddy
of mine came out the closet and this
gentleman is homoerotic and he came out
of the closet to me and I knew he was
gay forever because he sounded like a
gay man and because he walked around the
key was pretty much gay and he finally
came out of the costume I didn't know
what to do dude
so I just put my I put two of my fingers
in my mouth bro cuz I didn't know what
to do so
put my two fingers in my mouth and I put
one of my hands on his cheek my other
hand on his cheek and I know that's not
sign language or anything like that I
just I didn't know what to do but I
think some physical contact did let him
know I'm okay and you're okay you know
and everything's gonna be okay and I
accept you so sometimes a physical
contact to let people know you know just
they can feel that you know you ever get
that if you get that electricity when
you're walking across the floor like in
the library we used to have this
gentleman named Pierre and he was a
black gentleman and he was our librarian
and he was probably the only black
librarian in the 1980s or 90s and he we
used to run our feet along the carpet in
the library and then when he was resting
because he would rest involuntarily
he had that syndrome when you start
resting involuntarily
you know he got he you know he always
just hitting that snooze bar you know
the Lord was always hitting his own
hitting his snooze bar Pierre's you know
we should say resting Pierre that's what
we would say cuz he was always resting
and we would get that zap on us you know
you could rub your hands on you rub your
shoes along the carpet then pull up on
somebody and zap them this is sick I'm
in the neck again you know and so we
used to zap old Pierre and wile Ivan him
up get him back awake and bring him back
to life but that's what I feel like it
is whenever you if somebody likes you
and they touch you you notice you can
feel that so if you're in the friend
zone you want to get out of it sometimes
it's not other people putting you there
sometimes you just stay in there I think
get specific with your intentions let
them be known you know and I think
that's just that's the overall vibe of
this whole episode let them be known get
specific with your intentions and let
them be known but I appreciate you guys
calling in this week man it's been a
good episode I feel like I'll be BA I'm
gonna hit the patreon to it some more
you know put something up there for the
patreon errs and thank you guys so much
we got some really we got some new and
exciting things are gonna be happening
in the spring looking at a studio right
now thinking about having guests in on
Thursdays
we got a gentlemen Christopher Perez
who's coming in on Sundays and he's our
intern now and he's on you know and he's
excited and he's uh he's Mexican I guess
you know or Latino and he's fired up you
know handsome fella and he seems pretty
keyed up and you know and it's exciting
and dude he has ideas and he has energy
you know but Galloway was in this
Wednesday and he's you know helping out
and making amends for you know ruining
because we he and I ruined each other's
Thanksgivings by not getting an episode
put together correctly but you know
people are helping out people are
contributing you guys are helping out
you know by making the calls by
listening by subscribing if you haven't
subscribed subscribe on YouTube
subscribe on something else
iTunes we're gonna listen to another
call right here young fellow having a
problem onward with something Mike I
live in California too man thanks for
calling talk a lot about the dark arts
and I think I know I think my art
sometimes getting a lot darker than some
of your callers and listeners dark arts
baby your pain is tainted huh you got
that freaking that uh your pain is
tainted you got that dim trim let's hear
it myself yeah sometimes finding a lady
friend isn't easy especially I mean I
noticed in Los Angeles that's where I
live it's really tough but let's hear
more
banging trains and I know what you're
thinking pretty weird like no I
don't think it's weird and sick man you
know I mean people bang transvestites
somebody's having sex with transvestites
you know when you see a transvestite you
know that people are having sex with
them you know and if that's you that's
that's what you do
you know some people want it all you
know I'm indecisive sometime you want
the surf and the turf you want the soup
in the salad you know you want the creme
brulee and you want that shim Brule you
know something you want that hitter and
you want that spitter and that's where
it seems like you're at you just want it
all let's hear more you know getting out
there but sometimes I just put my boots
on and go to work yeah man
bothers me and keeps me up late at night
I'm worth basically no there's anybody
else out there starting with the same
dark arts - I'm thinking like you know
that self pleasure in this that's an art
but man boy man you stopping at the
train station boy all aboard huh all
aboard that wiener and vagine and that's
okay you know and I think you know what
I do have you know I actually know some
friends who have who have had who have
been in having sex with transvestites
and most of them it has been as an
accoutrement to their addiction you know
and that's part of like you know it's
sometimes they would get transvestite
prostitutes and I've never seen this you
know but I do have friends that have
shared that with me that that has been
their experience and so and those were
friends that were addicted to drugs so
you know I think there's some of that
out there that sometimes you want love
and you don't know what to get it from
and so it makes sense a transvestite
that's just a whole family in one you
know that's that 7-eleven
that's a 7-eleven for your you know for
your libido and for your heart cuz you
can you can be you're with a man a woman
could be a mother a father a brother a
nice and it's all in one it's all
encompassing
so you're getting a whole family right
there in one package of person so
there's something it's certainly
understandable man I don't think that's
a dark art if you're doing it in a
healthy environment you know if you're
you know I don't even think it's a dark
art if you're paying for set
you know unless it's a negative unless
it's gotten to the point where it's a
bad habit you know were you're resorting
to it in addition to cocaine use or drug
use or methamphetamine use if you're
getting wild like that if you be in that
frisky biscuit and trying to get up
there and lick lick somebody's
all their body whiskers and try to
change the oil with your tongue you know
if you play in the pipe and you play in
the pouch at the same time there's
something wrong with that you know but
if it's if it's an accoutrement of other
bad behaviors then it might be something
want to look at but look man if you're
out there you're out there enjoy your
life brother you know but decide before
this new year starts why don't you
decide for yourself that you're gonna be
happy with it and you're gonna quit
thinking about it you're gonna quit
judge if you're judging yourself for it
you know that's what I'm gonna try to do
got this beautiful art - I'm showing you
this if you're on the YouTube you can
see this beautiful fan art and I'll put
it up on my Instagram as well gentlemen
Chris brought this to me over there and
uh when I was in Canada and he's a
Canadian fella and that is beautiful man
and he really did it and I definitely
look up like I put on weight in this
photo all right let's take one more call
here thank you I just wanted to say I've
been doing stand-up for like three four
months now and my best jokes they're
kind of like their racial and I'm kind
of a white guy
you're either are you want dedi and I
know it's a it's you're not allowed to
be white in America anymore so I am
sorry to hear that brother homework do a
lot of I got a brother the 12 year old
adopted boy from China and I do a lot
like a Chinese bit where I'm like you
know they send him here in a crate
got out of the crate we had to feed them
off the dog back trying to boy back you
know that kind of thing and I always get
to laugh but I kind of like I don't know
sometimes it's kind of weird because
like I get them so you're doing them
back China boy jokes and you beat them
off of the dog because it's an old you
know stereotype of Asian people eat
animals and we discussed it last week on
the episode that Asian people are that
in some countries that in countries with
more poverty in them or more people and
less food that they that more things are
food and so yeah I mean dude you
leave me home for four days and you
leave me and there's a Datsun
there's a Datsun there's a Weimaraner in
the other room guarantee we'll both be
here when you get back home word like I
get that I'm white I don't know what do
you think about that like you think it's
okay to like pull that stuff out cuz
it's like my experience you but like all
through with he's okay so is it okay to
make fun of your brother and include him
in your material I think it's okay you
can have your experience and they're
part of your life you know in the end I
think it also it could be helpful to
bring it back around maybe talk about
what his experience must have been like
because then you get suss then the
audience gets to see it from his
perspective as well you know and then in
the future you know ask him you can
always ask him you know I remember
there's a joke my brother you should try
to make love to me when we were children
and I remember asking my brother if it
was okay that I could tell the story and
he said yes and he said look I love
being a part of your work you know and
so you know I was scared there's another
story I tell about where my sister
didn't want me talking about it and so
your family will let you know and you
can apologize if you're wrong
but I don't think that anything is
off-limits you know I don't think so I
think humor is the one thing that's
gonna save us you know cuz it's the one
thing that we all have inside of us is
the ability to laugh you know I'm
sitting in some of these clubs and I'll
say the word black you know or I'll say
um you know I'll say racism or I'll say
you know or I'll even mention a story
about a Chinese Mexican kid that I grew
up with and people get or unable to even
it's like I can't say certain words how
the hell can we live together and not
talk about even reference each other you
know I mean I think it would be a great
world if we amazing maybe if we were all
one color and lived in one magical place
but that's not realistic okay
that's not realistic I love the goal I
love the dream of it I love the idea of
it but you know I think everything is
okay to laugh about people will know in
your heart what's going on and I think
you have to walk try and walk the fine
line of not being mean when I look at my
earlier comedy when I was younger I do
find that I was mean about some things
because I had some anger in
and as I've been able to let that anger
go I've been able to share some of the
same stories and same attitudes but but
with a kinder tone and I find I'm
grateful for that I'm grateful for that
mild evolution that saw slowly happened
in me you know and sometimes it's it
comes and goes slow it comes and goes
slow but yeah I say keep laughs keep
keep going and if they get offended you
know you try and talk about why how
you're offended even that's one thing
I'm gonna start doing you know that's
one thing I'm gonna start doing so with
that said man we're gonna cut out here I
appreciate you guys calling there will
be a Thursday episode you know and if
you if you guys want to call in we could
we can make it about Christmas I don't
know what we're gonna you know what
we're gonna make it about I want to know
what's going on what do you what do you
want to get off of your chest from this
year let's do that what do you want to
get off of your chest from this year you
know that you don't want to take into
the next year with you
what are you tired of carrying around
you know I'm tired sometimes would be a
non-committal I'm tired of it you know
I'm tired of of of feeling inadequate
sometimes and not getting help for
myself you know I'm tired of you know
spending time with somebody that I care
about but being afraid to talk about
real issues that are in my mind for fear
of alienating them you know I'm tired of
feeling ashamed to be a man or stand up
for myself sometimes because of the way
the society is these days and makes us
feel you know I'm tired of sitting
around while people make fun of poor
people I'm tired of feeling like
everything gets blamed on poor people
and white people you know I'm tired of
not speaking up for myself
you know I'm tired of not being more
active you know I'm tired of not waking
up every day in seas in my day and if
I'm unable to because I'm feeling
depressed or something I'm tired of not
figuring out why I'm depressed or
getting to the bottom of that so I
can move on you know I'm tired of that
kind of stuff I really am I'm tired of
it we'll take this one call real quick
this came in a couple weeks ago and I
wanted to play it and I didn't but here
we go hey Theo this is JP and I love
them I'm a 35 year old male who's been
married two times and that for my second
marriage and the second one's going
pretty successful so far I just wanted
to address your fears being in a
relationship that you talked about last
week I think really man I'm like I said
I'm a plan I don't want to come off as
an here but I think you're just
kind of being a about it man
and somebody who's been through some
with women several times it's
always worth it in the end seems like
it's me if you get out of it alive you
know if you got some going on
with some women he said it's always
worth it in the end if you get out alive
and that's JP from Alabama but I think
the message was there was that you know
you're being a and and I think
there's some truth there you know I
think there's some truth there so that's
why I wanted her I want to get this
stuff all from my life you know can i
swimming around in this vagine anymore
you know I'm picking a path you know I
mean I want to know what I want I want
to be headed in my direction I'll be
making the most of my time and of my
effort because we deserve it we deserve
it we all do man you know and my cousin
got bit by a gay man out there on
Highland you know and this man was
dressed up like a baby deer we got each
other tiny sand who showed up I want to
thank animal man I want to thank the
caller's you know I want to thank you
guys giving advice for our young lady in
the friend zone and
and you can find links to everything at
the bottom of the YouTube remember to
subscribe remember to hit the hotline
nine eight five six six four nine five
two zero three we've got on word shirts
at Theo von comm slash store
we got a few new shirts in the store
there and I thank you guys for being a
part of my year I mean a part of my year
man I'm grateful to you that man asked
you feel like it your friends Colin you
know most of the time I do most of the
time I do
tiny once you make us feel big brother
[Music]
and while this plays I'm gonna open up I
got a few Christmas presents I actually
got a few Christmas presents that came
in I'm going to open them up here for
I'll just show you one of them while
this plays I'll show you I got a pillow
from the lady that's making the Bitcoin
movie the producer sent me this
beautiful pillow and I'll show you this
thing
[Music]
if you're on the youtubes you can see
that pillow Louisiana pillow
[Music]
another gift right here
tiny boy
[Music]
mr. my friends ever been DiBona
productions
[Music]
my friends at Vindobona productions who
make that show America's Funniest Home
Videos they gave me this book the Monty
Python's Flying Circus and it looks like
one of those books where everything and
it pops up when you open it so that's
pretty cool pop-up book so I'm pretty
excited to crack in on this I'll put it
out there on a coffee table or nobody
will ever read it but the people at
Vindobona productions my friend Lisa
black and Rebecca Donahue gave me this I
also got a beautiful card from Howie
Mandel and his family and I got a gift
from my new assistant Christopher Perez
but I haven't opened it but I'll let you
guys know next week what it is and thank
you guys for being a part of it and here
we go be good to yourselves that you
deserve it Merry Christmas
[Music]